This is the Orthodox Jewish gentleman
that admits Jesus is in the Talmud.
So, do not let them lie to you and tell
you
that figure in the Talmud is not Jesus.
Don't let Michael Licona mislead you,
deceive you.
The Talmud does speak about Jesus and he
admits it. He tells Sean McDowell,
"You know I believe Jesus existed not
because the Gospels are first-century
accounts, because the Talmud mentions
him. Did you know that?" I'm going to
play the clip. Let me repeat.
He told
Sean McDowell,
he doesn't believe Jesus is a myth. He
believes Jesus exists.
All right.
He told
Sean McDowell,
the reason why he believes he's not a
myth, the Talmud mentions him.
He's honest.
I really hope he comes to fall in love
with the Lord Jesus Christ. So, let's go
there and hear it from the horse's
mouth.
Let's go and hear it from the horse's
All right. Let's go here. from the
inside.
Phenomenal man, Sean.
Cuz he had a great father, Josh
McDowell. May the Lord Jesus
preserve us and we finish the race and
not fall in scandal like so many have.
So, let's go here.
Here you go. Jesus claimed to be. And I
think that's sort of the the central
question here. My understanding is
Jesus, in his life, he was not claiming
to be a Messiah. He was not trying to
start a new religion. These things sort
of came after the crucifixion. Would
that be an accurate assessment of of who
Jesus was and his mission in life? So,
two things.
>> And sorry, and this is operating under
the assumption, which I agree with, that
that Jesus actually existed as an
historical person. Sure. Yeah, I agree
with it. He does exist as an historical
person, but why? What's his reason?
Which you agree with, right? Just Okay,
good. All right, we don't have to start
there. Fair enough. I'm not ready to to
concede the point that he was the
Messiah, but I am ready to say he was an
actual person who who lived and died and
was operating during the temple period,
absolutely. And I'm not avoiding the
question, and you base that on the
gospel accounts and the extra-biblical
ones. Like what convinced you? No, I
don't base that off the gospel,
interestingly enough. I actually base it
on the Talmud. Um
the the the Talmud
was referencing Jesus. They the the
editors of the Talmud, which was really
finished in 500 CE, they were not afraid
of Christianity at the time because it
wasn't really existing as a religious
movement, and only once Christianity
became a religious movement, there was
much to fear. And so later editions of
the Talmud kind of censored their more
explicit references to Jesus. You heard
it from the horse's mouth.
You heard it from the horse's mouth.
You hear it?
You guys hear it, right?
They censored it later on.
You hear it?
David, when you find that link to redeem
Zoomer, let me cuz I'd like to share
that.
All right. I'm going to play that one
more time, but let him finish his point.
But the way I understand Jesus existed
is because well, our rabbinic tradition
actually speaks about him in in passing
and and in short in short clips, but but
they do acknowledge that there was this
person who was saying these things.
Totally. Okay. Hear it one more time.
Send this to Michael Lofton.
Okay, watch here. Just hear it one more
time. And I've have based it on the
Talmud. Um, okay. The The The Talmud
was
>> Hold on. A little A little earlier. Hold
on.
Let's go here.
Let's go here. Okay, watch here.
on the gospel accounts and the
extra-biblical ones. Like, what
convinces
>> No, I don't base that off the gospel.
Interestingly enough, I actually based
it on the Talmud. Um, Okay.
>> The The The Talmud
was referencing Jesus.
>> Yep.
>> They The The editors of the Talmud,
which was really finished in 500 CE,
they were not afraid of Christianity at
the time because it wasn't really
existing as a religious movement. And
only once Christianity became a
religious movement, there was much to
fear. And so, later editions of the
Talmud kind of censored their more
explicit references to Jesus. But, the
way I understand Jesus existed is
because, well, our rabbinic tradition
actually speaks about him in in passing
and and in short in short uh clips. But,
but they do acknowledge that there was
this person who was saying these things.
Totally fair. So, that makes sense. That
means he's been raised up on a diet
that Jesus is a mamzer, a bastard.
His mother braided hair, kept her hair
unkempt like Lilith.
He was sired by a gentile,
most likely a Roman pagan. And Jesus'
punishment for misleading Israel through
sorcery
is he's burning in boiling forever.
This is the part he didn't say.
See that?
This is the part he didn't mention.
You get it?
He did not mention that he would have
been taught by the rabbis
Yeshu,
which means may his name and memory
be blotted out forever, cursing him
because they don't call him Yeshua, they
call him Yeshu,
which is an acronym may his name a
memory be blotted out forever.
That his father was a Gentile cuz his
mother
was an adulterous
who though married or engaged slept with
another man
most likely a Roman soldier.
His mother was like Lilith, unkempt
hair, braided hair
and that
Jesus learned sorcery in Egypt misused
the divine name
deceived people into worshipping him as
God through use of magic and sorcery
and then the Jews had to them on the
evil Passover, which I'll be doing a
series on that.
And that God is now punishing him in
hell where he's burning and boiling
not just but boiling and he'll burn
there forever.
David, you said to me that you posted it
in the chat, so I don't know what you're
talking about, brother.
This is what he believes.
All right?
Go watch the series I did with Jason
Talbott. I'm going to do another part
what they said about Jesus being killed.
See?
I like this one.
I like what you said.
That's a That's a woman after my heart.
Assyrian, Syrioyo, Middle Eastern
Oriental Orthodox who's on fire for
Jesus.
Tough. That's what I mean. Like tough.
There you go. That's what he believes.
>> [laughter]
>> Now, let's get into the topic middle
man.
I'll probably add it to one of my
playlists. I like how she said it, man.
Yep, so that's what, you know
that's what he believes. Just telling
you that's what he That's what he's
taught.
It's not his fault. What do I mean?
He's born in a Jewish home that's
Orthodox.
This is what the rabbis teach teach him.
It's not his fault.
Guys, it's not his fault.
It's like
if I'm born a Muslim
in a Muslim home,
I'm taught Paul is Antichrist.
You understand? A lot of people did not
choose to believe what they believe,
to be born in that religious group.
They didn't choose to be Pakistani
Christian or Pakistani Muslim.
So, they just inherit the religion of
their parents
and they assume that their religion is
right and they assume that the other is
wrong. You understand my point?
If you send a $5,000 donation to
Patreon,
I'll think about teaching you. Okay, you
want me there?
So,
for instance, let's look at within
Christianity. Just let's look at it. Let
me give you another example.
Right?
Let me give you another example.
You, all of you who love Jesus Christ
and are part of his body, and I know
that. I believe that with my heart and I
pray I'm part of his body. Ask your
saints to pray for me.
All the [clears throat] saints.
I need their prayers and I acknowledge
them and love them all.
But, most of you did not choose the
particular church
that goes back to the apostles. If
you're Armenian
and you're in the Armenian
Apostolic Orthodox Church,
right? That's because that's the church
of your ancestors.
So, obviously, if you stay in that
church,
you believe I was born
in the right church. If you're a Greek,
you're born into a Greek Orthodox
Church. So, you already
believe that because I'm Greek and my
ancestors
converted to the Christian faith and the
Greek Orthodox Church is an ancient
church, This is the Church of Christ.
So, I'm born in the right church.
See, everyone thinks that.
You with me there?
Everyone thinks that.
Assyrian, I was born in the Assyrian
community.
I was born to parents who are part of
the Assyrian Church of the East. Ipso
facto, the Assyrian Church is a true
church.
Hardly, rarely do you find people
who will question whether
my particular church has the fullness of
the truth more than the next guy.
No.
Remind you, I really believe and I've
seen evidence that convinces me. That's
just me.
Oriental Orthodox and all those churches
that fall under that category.
Assyrian Church of the East.
Eastern Orthodox and all the churches
that fall under that category.
And Catholic
Church and all the Catholic rites. They
are the ancient church
started by the apostles and their
followers, preserved by the almighty
triune God in spite of their schisms and
hatred for one another.
Now, one of them has more of the
fullness of the truth than the other.
So, again, remind you,
one of you will have 99 cents of the
dollar. Someone has 98, someone has 97,
someone has 95. But you got the same
dollar and all of you have over 90 cents
of it.
Yep.
You got it?
So, you shouldn't debate whether the
other guy is a part of a true church.
No, the debate is, well, we have more of
the fullness of truth than you and we
articulate the same truth you believe in
better than you. So, we all believe
Christ is truly God, almighty God who
became flesh. He didn't stop becoming
man. He is God-man, glorified man with a
glorified physical body human nature.
But we articulate the union natures
better than you. Miaphysitism.
But you all believe he's the God man.
You get my point, right?
Right?
So just keep that in mind.
It's not just this Orthodox Jew.
It's not just the Muslim.
Even Christians, you assume
that hey, I'm born in a Roman Catholic
home, the Catholic Church is true. Well,
what if you
that same person like let's take
Annette. You were born in a Catholic
home because you're born Latina most
likely
because being part of the Lat- Latin
community,
you were born Roman Catholic.
What if you were born Greek and born in
a Greek Orthodox home? Then you would
think the Greek Orthodox Church is true.
See? That's why be careful. The same
measure you use will be used against
you.
If you want God to show you compassion,
love, and patience, and mercy, then
extend that to the other.
You know,
I may be
born in a church that though is
apostolic and has over 90 cents of the
dollar, it may not have
more of the fullness and truth than the
Eastern Orthodox. I believe it does, but
just in case
maybe they have more of it.
I want to be
cautious. I want to be humble, not
arrogant, and I want to be loving and
compassionate to the other so that the
Lord Jesus will extend that same measure
to me.
Right?
Do you hear me there? Keep that in mind.
Just keep that in mind.